you've interviewed a lot of rock and
rollers yes what can guys in rock and
roll whether it's guys in the 90s
whether it's the new generation of you
know indie rock whatever what can they
teach actors because the two are
different and I think actors are kind of
afraid of rock and roll mm-hm because
it's raw and it's scary and people don't
use a filter they tell you what they
think yeah but again what can actors
learn from these rock and roll you know
that's exactly it what you just said is
what I've noticed the difference between
musicians rock and roll musicians and
actors whether you are famous or not
they eat live and breathe it if you see
some dude walking down sunset you can
tell by the way he's dressed that he
plays in a band that he's some crazy
rock and roll guitar as you know he's
got bandanas on and bracelets and some
eyeliner and it's two o'clock on a
Tuesday afternoon and he's going to the
grocery store but he doesn't leave his
house unless he looks like that and it's
such an embodiment I've noticed like
with with rock and roll with the music
lifestyles it's such an embodiment of
your brand right of who you are of your
marketing of what you're putting out
there and that's something with us as
actors there's a little bit of a
challenge in a really finding out what
is your brand or what is your marketing
and and you know i see i see
progressions of people over time that
it's a natural progression when they
come to their brand and who they are and
then i see people where you're like
you're doing what didn't you just have
you know black care and now you have
blonde hair and you know like you know
what you mean like just different
completely like 360 changes in your leg
blue so maybe that's not an authentic
change rather than like a progression of
like into your brand but with like the
rock and roll musicians it's it's it's
an embodiment it's a live breathe I just
read and it's amazing that I just read
Guns and Roses is one of my all-time
favorite
and i just read reckless road which was
a biography and by just i mean like a
week ago it was a written by Mark Cantor
who his family is here they own Canter's
deli very very famous family in the
Hollywood area who was the best of
friends with EXO / is he deaf Stephen
back in like day one and what he did I
guess it's been out for less than 10
years probably more like five years he
had saved he had done a lot of photos he
was taking a lot of photos at the time
and even some recordings and he had
saved like every ticket stub every flyer
every everything and once he did it he
went like the group of collective and so
you put this book together and it's kind
of like a scrapbook it's like this huge
photo scrapbook but then you know with
texts and stories in between and it was
such an amazing story to see like how it
all came about from the moment they all
finally joined the same band to like you
know this disaster that disaster to then
record labels banging down the door to
them then getting like they were they
were all completely homeless poppers and
then all of a sudden they got in advance
and they all got like thirty thousand
dollars each and in the book he talks
about how like axl they wouldn't let him
open a bank account with his with Axl
Rose with the name Axl Rose and so he
refused to open a bank account and had
like thirty thousand dollars in his sock
like that night at like you know she'll
fated it was just like amazing to listen
to like all the behind-the-scenes stuff
and the magic that goes along but you
know what which ties back into what we
were just talking about is that as an
actor you're almost always solo you know
as a rock star you have your band
you have your family hopefully you know
sometimes their solo acts and sometimes
disastrous breakups occur but you have a
team of like four to five people and
everyone has their strengths and
weaknesses and so you know maybe you're
the promoter maybe you're the one that
schedules you know everything maybe
you're the one that has the steady job
and the money that supports the project
as actors were for solo a lot you know
like it's yeah we're we ought to really
our only competition you know at the end
of the day when it comes down to it
there's a gizzle you know what actors
and actresses out there and there's a
gizmo you know when roles but when the
rolls right for you it's yours but at
the same time you don't have anyone
kicking you in the pants saying it's
time to go to rehearsal because there's
like four other people waiting for you
you have to make those things happen on
your own and so it's always good to get
like those little groups together kind
of form your own bad I guess I need it
for my band maybe that's what I'm not
doing quite right I needed one gENBAND
look in the musicians learn from actors
I don't know I think I'd rather be a
rock star I mean there's a lot of
similarities with the self marketing and
the promotion I think they're more
discipline what do you think that
there's a lot of rock and roll or
whatever's on our music but they're all
despondent producers no I mean I think
it goes either way I mean there's like
it depends on the person you know
because there's there's actor friends of
mine that I know that call themselves
actors and you're like what are you
doing you're not yet you have no body of
work you have no classes you don't you
go to parties you know what I mean like
but but you're an actor especially here
in Hollywood maybe not so much in other
cities but here in Hollywood when you
first come in when you're first you're
first in your first Hollywood class and
you start meeting people in outside in
social circles and clubs and bars and
whatnot you're going to meet people who
say they're an actor or a musician or a
writer this or
so I guess at least and the bad side of
things at least of someone's out there
actively performing and playing shows
you know there's some kind of tangible
pneus to it as an actor it's hard to
have that tangible pneus because you
can't just go I mean you could go find
like an open mic night somewhere and do
things like that but I think maybe
musicians have it a little easier in
that aspect of that there's way more
avenues for them to get their talent
seeing and get out there and find out if
they you know if people are receptive to
their talent you know similar to doing a
play but yet that's still process and
gosh I don't know Karen there's so many
like crazy odds and ends and
similarities but your differences in
like at the end of the day though is
it's really individually whether you're
an actor musician rate or whatever
you've got to be putting in the work and
you've got to be doing it and you got to
get out there maybe there's more of a
chance in this day and age for musicians
to make money because they can go to
iTunes and they can sell you know the
indie level they can still sell copies
of their albums and whatnot as an actor
I've been trying to figure out what my
product is you know I'm like if I had a
product what could I sell you know um it
feels really cheesy ated like you know
hey by my t-shirt you know with my face
on it or something you know but a band
can do that you know and a band can go
to iTunes and put up their their music
so I think maybe and that aspect they
have it a little easier as far as
getting like a financial flow income at
this level where as an actor what do you
sell you put up your demo reel you put
up your head shots but that's really
cheesy if you've got like some kind of
website and you know by my head shot for
a dollar or something like
you